soir alexis non merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france le président
d'iti fuoco vide
une première réaction de l'étonnement
peut-être aussi de votre part de
l'étonnement non parce que emmanuel
macron rencontre beaucoup de monde un
tout le temps on l'a vu m enlever son
masque remettre une légion d'honneur au
président 6,6 en l'enlaçant dans ses
bras il y beaucoup de contacts ces
derniers temps on lui souhaite un prompt
rétablissement évidemment apparemment ce
serait une forme légère de la maladie
donc pas de pas d'inquiétude ce qui
serait bien dans le cadre d'un bilan de
santé du président parce que je ne crois
pas qu'il ait publié de bilan de santé
c'est de savoir quel va être le
traitement que va suivre
emmanuel macron et savoir s'il avait un
traitement préventif auparavant ce qui
est choquant en revanche c'est de voir
que pour les cercles de pouvoir les
règles ne s'appliquent pas ce dîner il
était bien après 20 heures les
restaurants sont fermés mais on a dîné
hier avec des responsables de la
majorité jusqu'à minuit et demi et vous
aviez autour de la table bien plus de
six personnes
donc avec emmanuel macron le voit bien
ces gestes barrières ces mesures
sanitaires c'est faites ce que je dis
mais ne faites pas ce que je fais donc
si aujourd'hui il est lui malade ça fait
beaucoup de cas contacts autour de la
table dont françois bayrou vous l'avez
dit christophe castaner jean castex
richard ferrand mais les conseillers des
lisez aussi alexis colère monsieur
solaire et bien d'autres que des hommes
autour de cette table qui sont
maintenant qu'à contacter et puis avant
eux
bien sûr les leaders européens puisque
emmanuel macron les a vus il ya très peu
de jours certains qui se mettent à
l'isolément qui vont se faire tester
puisque on ne sait pas quand et mal
macron attrapé ce virus et depuis quand
il est contagieux
alors quelle image alexis paul ince ça
donne du président de la république on
imagine qu'il y a selon les cas
peut-être deux opinions mais ils n'ont
pêche on parle beaucoup l'opposition
ironise en tout cas sur le devoir
d'exemplarité depuis ce matin il ya de
quoi
parce qu'il faut voir que la majorité
n'a pas été avare de petits mots un
moralisateur il sentencieux rappelez
vous c'était le préfet l'allemand qui
disait si vous êtes malade c'est que
vous n'avez pas respecté les mesures de
confinement
richard ferrand qui disait si vous êtes
malade ou bien attention si vous prenez
des risques c'est vraiment irresponsable
et puis plus récemment jean castex ce
qu'ils disaient que la première des
responsabilités c'est de ne pas tomber
malade pour ne pas engorger les hôpitaux
donc oui les les oppositions se font
plaisir et à raison et peuvent taper sur
ces moralisateurs de la république en
marche qui finalement ont fait tout
l'inversé de ce qu'il prônait ce qu'ils
imposaient aux français et voilà un
président qui tombe malade alors même
qu'il a fait en sorte d'imposer aux
français un régime sanitaire qui rend
fou pour beaucoup qui empêche les
commerces d'ouvrir qui a vu fermer des
rayons de produits non essentiels où
l'on n'a rien compris puisque les métros
étaient blindées et les salles de
spectacles sont restés vides et reste
toujours vide 1 rappelons le des
secteurs entiers qui n'ont pas redémarré
et dont on ne sait pas quel va être
l'avenir
donc oui on peut vraiment fustigé la
façon dont cette crise sanitaire a été
gérée et de voir qu'aujourd'hui le
président responsable de ces conseils de
défense à répétition où tout était
décidé derrière des portes closes et
sans transparence du tout est
aujourd'hui malade donc on peut demander
de la transparence sur son bilan de
santé sur le traitement qu'il va prendre
et puis il ya aussi cette campagne de
vaccination qui commencent ou finalement
c'est jean castex qui devait parler
aujourd'hui devant les sénateurs il n'a
pas pu puisque qu'à contacter et c'est
olivier ferrand qui lui depuis quelques
semaines a décidé d'ignorer la
représentation nationale député ou
sénateur qui s'est bien retrouvé obligé
en tant que ministre de la santé
d'expliquer le plan on vit quand même
des moments particuliers en france où un
ministre de la santé refuse de
s'exprimer devant la représentation
nationale sous prétexte qu'il a beaucoup
de travail on peut comprendre mais c'est
quand même son rôle puisque on est en
train de mettre en place un plan de
vaccination massif puisque on a beaucoup
de questions sur les vagues successives
sur les confinements sont ils utiles ou
non sur ce virus dont on ne sait encore
pas assez de choses donc oui et mal
macron n'est pas le seul chef d'état
bien entendu avoir attrapé
et ce virus donald trump plus récemment
mais aussi ball sonar au brésil boris
johnson
au royaume uni le président algérien qui
s'est toujours en allemagne sous
traitement voilà donc c'est pas le
premier c'est pas le dernier
mais compte tenu de ce qui est imposé en
français on attend un peu plus
d'exemplarité de la part de nos
dirigeants
on imagine ou alexis poulain que la
manière de communiquer va être
extrêmement importante c'est un exercice
d'équilibriste qui va falloir mener pour
les équipes de l'elysée comment
communique-t-on dans ces cas parce que
ça peut avoir des conséquences plutôt
positive mais aussi plutôt négative
oui alors on a vu à la façon dont a été
géré la communication je disais des
chefs d'état qui ont attrapé ce virus
l'humilité du côté de boris johnson qui
est s'est retrouvé en soin intensif qui
a fait un discours très court qui a
remercié les personnels soignants le est
net chez ce qu'avait fait un travail
formidable
le retour au guerrier conquérant de
donald trump en pleine campagne
électorale qui s'est retrouvé lui aussi
hospitalisé et qui revient en
hélicoptère dans le jardin de la maison
blanche maintenant j'ai vaincu le virus
je sais ce que c'est n'ayez pas peur on
va le battre ensemble donc emmanuel
macron pourrait choisir une de ces deux
routes humilité ou bien combatif
vu son âge il ne risque pas grand chose
il n'a pas de conditions particulières
il ya une forme légère donc ce sera sans
doute l'humilité se rassemblent le fait
de dire qu'il n'a pas été assez
précautionneux à ses responsables aussi
mais c'est rare quand il fait une
autocritique donc on peut s'attendre au
pire
et puis une gestion qui va sans doute
enrobé la campagne de vaccination qui va
commencer en disant eh ben c'est pas
plus mal regardé après tout si on veut
s'en sortir le plus vite possible nous
allons tous se faire vacciner le plus
vite possible pour au moins ceux qui
peuvent donc on va utiliser sa les
communicants de l'élysée vont sans doute
se saisir de ce moment là pour en faire
une promotion de la politique sanitaire
des macros depuis le début même si lui
ne l'a pas respectée une seule seconde
et puis la deuxième chose qu'on tenait
en qu'on pourrait être en attente
en tant que citoyen c'est la
transparence je le disais c'est quel
traitement va recevoir emmanuel macron
at il eu un traitement préventif en
amont et va-t-il publier des bilans de
santé
ce que faisait françois hollande avant
lui
parce que la santé des présidents en
france c'est quand même un sujet
sensible
rappelez-vous georges pompidou qui
jusqu'à la dernière minute à gouverner
avec un cancer ont caché à l'époque ces
bilans de santé françois mitterrand qui
prend le pouvoir avec un cancer et qu'il
la cache et aussi pendant longtemps
donc aujourd'hui on peut demander
davantage de transparence
compte tenu de ce qu'on demande aux
français et de transparence avec les
lois liberticides comme le droit de
sécurité globale et puis ces mesures
sanitaires qui rendent les français fous
merci alexis poulain éditorialistes
merci à vous